and we did it and he tweeted it out
and he went from 20 000 followers to i
think close to 100 000 followers at this
point in 24 hours
[Music]
andrew what's going on
the return of andrew
we promised that we promised that you
would come back
and um
sometimes that's just something we say
we're like oh we gotta do this again
sometime but this was a real one so uh
we're like all right when do you want to
do it
yeah
we had like what like 20 things to get
through we got through like four
so what do you guys say we also [__]
around this time and not not address
half of the topics again and set it up
for a third parter i want to i do want
to [__] one thing and this kind
maybe andrew you'll know a little bit
about this but listen let me tell you
guys a story really quick andrew do you
know a guy named chris pronger
no
he is a hockey player he played in the
nhl for like 20 years or something he um
it's from canada i think ontario and uh
he played in st louis blues he's like
the fifth or sixth or seventh highest
paid player of all time
so
for some reason he reached out to me on
twitter and i started talking to him and
then we went and got dinner and he
wanted to he's like hey tell me how this
twitter thing works like it looks cool
like should i try this i was like yeah
dude here's what we're gonna do tomorrow
call me on zoom and
the day before you call me send me five
titles of what you think a tweet could
be and we'll just sit and i'll just kind
of like write while you talk and i'll
just find the interesting stuff uh that
you that you're saying and we'll go from
there and we did it and he tweeted it
out
and he went from 20 000 followers to i
think close to 100 000 followers at this
point in 24 hours and the tweet was read
by 10 million people and got 30
something thousand likes
and
this is the fifth time i've done this so
i did this with my friend ramon
and he got featured in all this he got
he got on the how i built this podcast
and business there because of that i did
it my friend val who same thing we did
it with um i helped do it with my friend
anthony who talked you guys see the
tweet thread about him living in africa
and eating
like only meat with like his the tribe
he was staying with anyway
this is this is crazy if you just take
interesting people and it's not like i
did any of the work they were just
talking their stories i just helped them
write it it's pretty wild how how
this game works
and what were the stories what did you
share
chris's was easy it was just let me let
me let me tell you one because
let me tell you one of them because he
got picked up by bro bible so the bro
bible headlines did it really nhl star
chris pronger ex-nhl star chris pronger
shares traps that pro athletes fall into
including spending one million at a
strip club
and um so why do you how did it get so
many like so much traffic right away i
think because the story got picked up by
bigger outlets like bro bible too so
that adds a lot of fuel to the fire
it's hilarious yeah and i retweeted it
early on and but i think it's just like
a he's already somewhat famous and cool
and like
i think sometimes they like i'm not
trying to say this to brag because the
reality is is like it's not that hard
because the guy is already like a big
deal and has an interesting life and
like
who's if you earned a hundred bucks dude
he's not that big of a deal
like well but what i mean is not that
many people know chris pronger but what
i mean is if you earn 100 million
dollars in as a professional athlete you
have like one you have there's only a
thousand there's only 100 people who
have that insight that you have
so like the insights that are i wonder
what you like if you think about the
value
you think about the value of what you
did for him that's insane like if you
went to someone and said hey i'm going
to get you 10 million impressions on a
tweet or i'm going to get you 100 000
followers what's that worth people pay
like that's like honestly i'd say it's
like a million dollar tweet or something
that you gave him
well uh
yeah but you can't guarantee that right
so it's like a hard service to sell
oh dude you should do it right here
right now you should say i will write i
will write tweets for you but depending
on the outcome and the number of
followers you have to pay me a certain
amount so it's totally variable
um yeah that would actually be worth
your time so andrew i um
i
uh
had a right before this i was on a a
twitter spaces with logan paul i was
talking to logan paul
so you're only the second most famous
person i've talked to this morning
only a little bit more famous holy crap
that's crazy what's he doing these days
he just launched a um like a marketplace
like a
fractional ownership
nft things so he basically created this
thing called liquid marketplace where
like i don't know if you've seen but
he's really into
pokemon cards like charizard cards and
stuff like that like that's been his
thing over the last few years like these
collectible
either sports cards or pokemon cards and
so what he did today was he launched a
fractional like a rally road style
uh marketplace where he would put up
like you know his charizard card and you
could just buy like a share of it rather
than he bought the thing for two million
and you could buy you know a piece of
the a piece of the the pie there so
that's what he launched today so that's
why he was kind of doing like a
promotional thing
and i i was like i'll just shoot my shot
and so i just like you know raised my
hand or whatever and went and talked to
him
it's crazy the power of a the moat of a
personal brand and a following right
like those guys they can build they
could build 100 businesses off of their
following and that chris pronger guy the
reason that's so valuable is he can now
start his own business doing whatever he
wants selling shirts selling nfts
starting a consulting business managing
money for other hockey players you know
whatever off of that hundred thousand
people the optionality of it is insane
obviously the downside of it is if
you're logan paul you're logan paul and
you've ultimately got to be the face
did you um yeah did you just say sean
i was just telling him
go ahead
sorry we got a little delay uh yeah i
was just telling andrew i talked to a
little ball this morning that's the that
was the on the phone or in front of
people
in in front of you on a twitter spaces
just randomly i saw that i was listening
but i i didn't his name on twitter is
not
i think it had a nickname on it so i
couldn't tell if it was logan uh was he
cool
yeah he was cool i mean he was like
promoting his thing which is you know he
was so he that's why he was he was on
there uh like because he launched a new
like rally road competitor basically
and uh
and so i was just joking around with him
basically that i know you guys covered
it in the middle of a couple different
things
um we uh but that personal brand thing
andrew you kind of got that early on
because you built your personal brand
back i think before a lot of people were
doing it um because you kind of built it
i would say pre-twitter even was that
right like did did you kind of have a
blog following before twitter or was it
all on twitter yeah i had a blog and
stuff but honestly like we're pretty
quiet until coved and then during kovid
i was bored and lonely and wanted to
talk to people and so going on podcast
was like a way to socialize um and then
i realized the power of it like once i
started getting uh you know thirty
thousand forty thousand twitter
followers i realized that when i talked
about a business i was incubating i had
our first thousand customers in a split
second and so from my perspective you
know i talked about last time about
being like a dust bowl farmer mindset of
what if you lose everything there's such
power in that you could literally go
bankrupt you could lose all your
businesses you could reboot in two days
with a business idea if you have a
twitter following and no one can take
your twitter following away obviously
dude you were not low-key before twitter
you were famous before that yeah yeah
thank you exactly well no no i'm saying
like i i i wasn't i was i was never i
wasn't on a single major podcast and i
was i was well known like when i went
south by southwest there'd be people all
the time recognizing me
um from twitter but that was a very
small nerdy community or whatever so i
was well known within like the design
community but that was it
all right well whatever you say i feel
like before covid we had you on the
podcast and it was already one of the
more popular podcasts because you were
on it and people were like people
already knew your story so i don't know
i feel like you might be uh
the timeline in your head might be a
little bit different than
than kind of at least the way i
perceived it which was
you were famous you were famous when we
started the podcast yeah we started the
podcast before covet so
that's the word yeah my perception is
like all of it has just been last three
years or whatever can i give you guys
saying it's true that like
you you your personal brand does like
kind of give you it's a door that opens
more doors
uh but the downside is you have to say
you're you have to say to yourself i'm
building my personal brand which is one
of the lamest statements you could say
so you know if you can live with that if
you can sleep with that at night then it
then it works out for you i know that
it's hard for me and sam to to do that
can we give you that's kind of why i
haven't started my own podcast or
consistently tweeted or anything all
right i like i to be honest like i'm
hacking your audience right i'll come on
here once in a while when i have things
to say but i don't want to have to
always come on and always tweet and when
i was tweeting consistently i was
driving myself crazy because i was
constantly going like okay what's my big
tweet today
can we um let me give you let me give
you guys an update on the pod i don't
know if i told you this sean or you
andrew so
and then we'll get into andrew's stuff
when we first started i think i told
sean or he told me i was like let's just
get to a hundred thousand downloads an
episode and i bet we can do that so sean
we are now not consistently for all
episodes but they just told me that a
lot of a couple of our episodes are now
getting over a hundred thousand
downloads which is like pretty it's
pretty good
wow
that's no that's been the goal for all
of like a while like i feel like i've
been that's been the north star of
what would it mean to like kind of make
it in podcasting it was like if we could
do it where a hundred thousand downloads
per episode because everybody else
bullshit's like and we do this too like
we get this many million downloads a
month but it's like yeah you just pump
out volume and like you know great the
only test that really matters for a
podcast how many lists per episode do
you get uh that's like the best metric
you can get and uh
i remember we were saying the hundred
thousand number back when we had like
under
i feel like slightly under 10 000 per
episode at that time that's when i first
kind of put that out there and then it's
just been like climbing since then
that's kind of crazy that it even
happened without us like it's kind of
like when i looked away from it and
stopped paying attention to it like sure
enough compounding just worked and it
like got there you know without me
having to stress it in december or no
january one of the one of the last
couple months we crossed two million
downloads per month that year prior that
same time i think was 500 000 and so i
my prediction is i think we can get hit
three million by december i've got no
math or anything behind that but i think
that seems like it could happen
so anyway just want to give you the
biggest
like tim ferriss do per episode do you
know i have to imagine he's a in the 500
000 to million range
i think he's probably even a little bit
higher than that i know that bill
simmons or joe rogan i forgot which one
it was i was looking to at the time
they're they're two of the biggest
i remember they were getting like three
or four million downloads per episode um
i think it was bill simmons at the time
three or four million downloads per
episode is what he was getting and he
was like consistently in the top five
you should do you should track though
think about like um so tim ferriss has
been podcasting for what eight or nine
years or whatever and that's how long it
took him to get to that scale you guys
might actually be growing faster than
tim ferriss if you chart it out
well i'm already six over six feet so i
did outgrow him a while back
now
goddess you are a very dad
dad all right let's do one of the let's
do some of these topics um
you got a bunch on here i'm just going
to say them out loud and i have no idea
what these mean but i'll just pick the
ones that sounds most interesting
we were we were having a text thread we
were kind of um
texting about the idea of getting rich
fast versus getting rich slow taking a
big swing versus doing something boring
dude i forgot i thought that was on the
podcast because
no that was a text message we should do
that andrew can you frame it uh because
i think you had you had a good take and
i'm also going to give you the advantage
of framing the frame the debate a little
bit uh
what is the debate here so i think i
think anyone who's in the tech world um
generally you read headlines about
people who swung big and they they won
big like jeff bezos
and i always say for every jeff bezos
there's 100 jeff bozos right so the guys
that tried they failed they didn't raise
the convertible debt in 1999 that
allowed amazon to survive or you know
they timed it slightly wrong or they
were in the wrong market or whatever it
is um and so if you think about it you
know on one hand startups um are like a
house like would you would you buy a
house that had an eighty percent chance
of being worth zero a ten 10 chance of
making your money back and had a 10
chance of making you rich right and then
let's say there's another house and that
house there's an 80 chance of giving you
a pretty solid return 10 chance of zero
and a 10 chance of a poor return which
of those houses are you going to buy and
if you think about it you know when you
start a business you're really saying
i'm going to put 5 to 15 years of my
time into this right so i am i've
certainly chosen
you know the boring house the 80 chance
of solid return 10 chance of zero 10
chance of poor return uh i'd be curious
to know you know how you guys think
about it
sam you want to go first
so i think your numbers are i think your
idea is right the problem that i had
when we talked about this was i think
your numbers are wrong like the whole 80
percent 10 percent now i i'm gonna let
you talk about any numbers that you want
to talk about with your life if you
don't want to talk about anything then
don't even bring it up but let's just
say that so everything i'm saying right
now is just made up let's just say that
you
you want a business that makes 10
million dollars a year
okay or no let's say that you want to
get a net worth of 50 million by the
time you're 50.
how much do you think that you would
need to make a pr profit to get a 50
million dollar liquid net worth how much
profit do you think that you would need
if you started that business at 30. i
would think that you would need a profit
i actually
go
i did the math on this actually before
and i wrote it down so if you have a
million dollars at age 30
and you can invest you can produce uh
profits of
maybe 300 to 500k a year at between ten
to twelve percent you can have a hundred
million dollars by 60 with compounding
so say that okay
million dollar net worth is your stock
so let's say you have a million dollars
let's say you have a million dollars at
age 30 and you start a business and that
business produces 500k a year and you
just take that 500k a year and you
reinvest it and you manage to rein to
invest it at about 10 which is a little
above
historical market returns let's say that
you're a good investor you're a nick
huber you're gonna just put it in steady
eddy real estate that outperforms a
little bit or something there's a full
100 million dollars by 60. yeah but
there's a flaw here which is do you have
you're assuming that you have zero
living expenses
sure yeah i'm not talking i'm not really
addressing that first so you're just
talking about i guess the point 300 the
number you need the number you need
the number you need to start with does
it doesn't need to be that big like a
small number can compound into something
staggering if you have a long enough
time horizon especially if you're out
performing 10
i think is quite low um compared to what
you can earn with skills so let's go
backwards so you said 100 million by 60.
and
i think the trick with most compounding
is it all kind of comes to you at the
end the last two cycles three cycles is
where you make all the money so so
backtrack what do you add at 50 and 40
in that world i don't know we don't get
public math i just did the headline
calculator you can kind of you can kind
of guess if you're at a 100 at 60 you're
probably
in the range of 50 at 50.
yeah you basically double every seven
years right at that pace so you're at
seven and seven percent doubles every
ten years 50 million
ish
which is sick that's right that's sick
okay
here's here's the question so you know
everyone loves to point at people who
are sitting on massive paper gains like
let's say um let's say that sam started
a startup and vc's invested at a 5
billion dollar valuation
in reality that doesn't mean sam sam's a
billionaire on paper but he's not going
to realize that until the company ipos
maybe he takes a small secondary maybe
he's got a 10 million 20 million dollar
liquid net worth but he's really not a
liquid billionaire until that company
ipos or sells to somebody and typically
the timeline even in a tech startup is
15 years right and so my argument is you
know you can take a big swing with a
venture bet but i mean statistically you
can argue all you want but most venture
businesses fail right at least an eighty
percent failure rate and maybe five at
mo five percent at most go on to be
something at scale and large right so i
think what i advocate isn't uh go uber
conservative and go get a salary or go
buy a dry cleaner and work there for the
rest of your life it's more what's in
the middle what's the third door and i
like to look at somebody like nick huber
who found a niche and he said look i'm
going to go buy a bunch of self storage
businesses these are businesses that
have been around for 100 years i have a
very specific view on how to make them
more profitable and he knows he can earn
between 15 and 40 percent buying a bunch
of those he just does that for the next
10 years he's gonna be worth hundreds of
millions of dollars
yeah i'm actually with you i think uh
i i did this rant on the podcast that
nobody liked which was that
you're an idiot if you go for the
olympics uh like going for the olympics
is a trap that you know society has
tricked you into giving up your entire
life to like turn yourself into a human
tool uh that can just you know bob
bobsled at one tenth of a second faster
than anybody else
and uh you know people didn't like that
because everybody likes the olympics and
we're supposed to honor our athletes and
blah blah blah but basically venture
like venture back startups is the same
thing it's the olympics of business
where you're basically saying okay i'm
going to
swing for this billion dollar prize
which only point one percent of the the
startups are gonna be able to you know
like to achieve this type of outcome
and if i miss i get essentially zero
that's kind of changed nowadays because
you get to maybe take secondaries along
the way if you make progress but like
a lot of times i would say the average
you know the median result is
essentially zero or you know you've
underpaid yourself by
50 to 75 percent of market salary during
those you know seven years that you
seven to ten years you spent trying to
do it
um and you worked way harder and you had
a worse lifestyle the whole time so you
know like the venture the venture thing
is like the olympics thing you sacrifice
your your lifestyle
for this very rare and often like
you know like at least in the olympics
case sort of a trivial you know here's
here's a piece of metal um you know at
least at least with startups if you if
you hit big you do become a billionaire
so so that that that does pay off
but i'm i kind of think that the venture
path is that and you really only do it
for ego is my like my current
understanding of it which is like either
you do it because it's your calling
meaning
you stumbled into a business opportunity
or a problem you tried to solve it just
so happens to be that the way this looks
is going to be like a winner take all
massive massive business if you do it
right
or
you are like i want to play the ego
olympics and i want to
prove that i am the toughest smartest
you know entrepreneur in the world and
so i'm gonna go down this path and like
everybody will cheer you on the media
will cheer you on because hey what's it
to them you sacrifice yourself for their
their pleasure uh the investors will all
cheer you on and call you a hero because
what's it to them they get to go home
every day at 4pm and you know to their
house in atherton they don't they don't
care you know how many hours it takes
you for your like low probability of
success they have a portfolio
um you know so really it's the
entrepreneur who in some ways i feel
gets tricked into it i say that as
somebody who who in many ways was
tricked into it um not by anybody's evil
just by the way that the game is set up
and now i've come to the realization
that like
more nimble small lightweight businesses
that provide like a lot of cash flow or
businesses that you just buy instead of
trying to start a new genius idea from
scratch
is definitely the way to go from a
logical rational perspective you can
still choose to do the other one because
you want to do it it's more fun to you
but the logic and reasoning is so far on
the side of
going for cash flow you know cash flow
business that promotes like you know it
gives you an awesome lifestyle from
essentially year one
or buying a business that's already
working and just using your intelligence
to grow it is like a far
better path on paper than the venture
path and i say that as somebody who
kind of
my natural inkling is to go towards that
venture path because it's so sexy
well and also i mean it can all go away
on the venture path that can all go away
so fast right
and i think the reason why it's not done
as often is people are attracted to get
rich quick right nobody wants to get
rich slow and like sean said
the only way to get rich right now is
like someone is in crypto and they're
liquid and they have a massive gain but
those stories are so few and far between
if you want to get rich by building a
business even if on paper you're a
billionaire in year two my argument is
you're not liquid until 10 years 15
years anyway right it's very rare that
you start a business on year one and in
year five you're a liquid billionaire
and to me ultimately liquidity is what
matters so often in these things right
either you have cash flow or you can
sell your stock um or you can use it in
some way
have you met uh michael acton-smith
you've heard his name
he's the co-founder of calm but before
that he had um what was the name of his
brand moshi monsters i think it is is
that it's either minnow or motion
monster i think it's moshi monsters so
he was in the uk and he created
essentially like a pokemon
uh type of phenomenon so like i think
moshi it was in the uk it was like this
children's kind of like um there was
like these characters and then you would
like uh i don't know like it was like a
game or something like that it's like
this online little world you would go
into and do this and that turned into
many things it was a brand that turned
into many things they put her they
slapped those characters on shampoo and
started selling it over there and he
dreamed of having a theme park and you
know he's a really like big dreamer big
thinker type of guy super creative uh
you know you wouldn't you wouldn't have
created that in the first place this
like phenomenon like like a pokemon or a
digimon or you know these like these
brands that just catch fire i think at
one point like one in three kids in the
uk were playing it um so it was like you
know just an insane like cultural
phenomenon and it was valued over a
billion dollars and he was the [__]
man and he was you know he looks like
russell brand if you see him like he's
just like this like kind of like you
know
good looking like wait does this guy
have sex in public he seems like a guy
who has sex in public and it's like you
know he's got this free love energy and
if you meet him you're like
yeah exactly he's got like you know he's
got scarves he's you know maximum two
buttons up on a collared shirt so like
you know the guys the guy's walking
around with two buttons right so he's
just living his best life and so he had
the persona and then he had the the
movement to back it up and it just
seemed like this is a type this is the
type of guy who crea he's like a walt
disney type of guy who creates this type
of phenomenon and you know richard
branson loves everybody loves it and
then sure enough you know they kind of
got ahead of their skis and all of a
sudden you know like whatever third
grade came around for those second
graders and they were like you know what
i don't care about moshi monsters
anymore i have moved on to the next
thing and it's like overnight the
business starts losing relevancy the
characters start losing relevancy and
like nobody's blind nobody's buying the
plush toys and the tv show doesn't want
to get made anymore whatever they
started to unwind essentially
it was very hard for them to like
reverse that cycle because
uh you know like as fast as you can
climb as a like fad phenomenon
uh that's as fast as it can unwind and
so i i don't know exactly what his net
worth was but i'm you know he was the
main guy and it was the company was
worth over a billion dollars i'm sure he
was worth hundreds of millions of
dollars on paper
but never got to realize it and then
basically had to start back over from
scratch as like
uh you know
just a guy and as you know just a guy
who who's like went through this went
through this like roller coaster but
like didn't have the money to show for
it
which makes it even more amazing that
they you know he went and and helped
seed calm like co-found calm and then
joined calm and helped grow calm into
like a multi-billion dollar brand so
he's kind of done it again and uh i just
think that's amazing
um i had the original agency and in the
early days the agency barely made any
money but it was a couple hundred
thousand dollars and
i read about the
base camp guys you know doing these uh
sas products and stuff and i was like
man i want to make money when i sleep
that sounds amazing and so i started
just taking most of my profits and
starting um you know sas software
companies by the way you set up 90 10
right you put 90 back into the business
into new stuff or whatever
you live in the early days it was
probably 80 20 but then over time i
ramped it up so basically i was taking
the majority of the profits anything i
didn't need to live on was almost all
going into incubating businesses i
incubated a bunch and you know some of
those businesses ended up being worth uh
you know one i sold for seven million
bucks and was producing
600 700k year of profit or something
like that so i was i made a lot of bets
with that money and ended up
compounding into something significant
but then i ended up continuing to take
that money and just do the 80 20 90 10
strategy of always investing and i
really started making a lot more money
when i went from starting businesses
to buying businesses
and investing
which i started about seven years ago
hold on those numbers don't make sense
yeah
tell you sounds like
20 million 200 net income
well no i mean no no no so so it's like
you know let's say let's say let's say
metal abs revenue is a million dollars
we made 500k of profit
and um
so that's what's left over at the end
after we pay taxes and stuff i'd take 80
of that 500k and i'd use it to start
more businesses right i would just do
this on a monthly basis whatever was
left over in the bank account that i
didn't need to run the business i would
go and i'd use it to start yet another
business
and i you know i've been doing that for
15 years now and we're are i think you
know all of our businesses together
worth over a billion dollars
did you
do you know how much you were
compounding so for example you took the
money and you either started a business
or bought like controlling share
in an existing business versus just
saying i'm gonna put this into real
estate or the stock market or angel
invest or whatever
um
how much additional lift do you think
you got to meaning like at what percent
were you compounding
by doing the extra work of like
identifying and buying businesses and
owning them versus like if you had done
a more kind of like hands-off strategy
which maybe let's say
i think somebody like you could have got
10 to 15 consistently
i think i could if i was passive i could
have got eight to 12 percent right
putting it in real estate stocks that
kind of stuff by buying businesses um
you know there's a lot of advantage in
that we could use a little bit of debt
because we controlled the whole business
right so you can get the bank to give
you 20 or 30 percent of it which adds a
lot of lift on your return and then we
were buying these businesses
anywhere from three to ten times
earnings and then we would usually
within the first two years we would find
ways to double the business within one
to two years so you start to think about
it and you go okay well that's a kind of
two to five year payback depending on
what's happening that's based on cash
and then the actual value of the
business as you grow their earnings
increases over time right so the numbers
start getting very big very quickly
especially when you've done that you
know 20 times so what do you think was
the
like what do you think was the
compounded rate
well i don't know how long the last but
it goes back to at the end of the day
you know when i started i was making you
know 200k 100k a year and today our
businesses make you know over 50 million
dollars
of profit across everything
so so what what uh what percent rate do
you think you you were able to generate
you think you were compounding at like
uh i think probably in the end it's it's
something or we did the math a couple
years ago um because we raised a fund
and i think it was like 40 40 some
percent now keep in mind you know that
was at a time where not that many people
were doing what we were doing so you
know it's gotten more competitive over
time and those are small deals it's
really easy to compound at high rates
when you're doing small deals as you do
bigger ones i think we'll probably slow
down on that um but it's not a number i
think about i i you know i never was
like i want to compound at 44 i was like
i just want to make my money back in a
reasonably safe way i want to buy great
businesses and i want to feel good about
what i do
that's crazy to me because you're andy
munger
you uh you know the whole buffet monger
like philosophy is based on compounding
over a long period of time and the
number one variable is time how long
you're going to do it for and what's the
rate right that's like the two totally
key things even if you generate you know
okay let's drop the rate down to 15 or
10 percent it's still hundreds of
millions of dollars right that's what's
crazy about compounding is you don't
need to outperform massively you just
need to do you know a little better than
everybody else and if you do as well as
everyone else you're still good
and
all right let me just ask this question
which was two things of your businesses
how many of them do you actually think
can last 20 30 40 years and also
if you can buy any company right now
internet related business
what are a handful that you like that
you like you know just to give an
example to me and sean the listener of
like things that you would look for you
know not actually something you can buy
but something that like this is what i
want and name a very specific one yeah
so um you know think about accenture
right so accenture i forget it was part
of one of the big five consultancies and
then it got spun out but basically they
help people do like um consulting
strategy digital transformation that
kind of stuff that business will
definitely exist for the next 30 years
um you know i don't know why it wouldn't
and in the same vein i think like meta
lab and our agency services businesses
you know we're really early in every
business turning into a tech company
right over the next 20 years more and
more companies will have to build
software
and go digital and i think there's only
so much talent so i think those are
tremendous businesses for the next 20
years i don't know how to predict
over very long times
aeropress is a business i think will
exist in 50 years
you know i don't see any reason why it
wouldn't will it have the same
competitive advantage as it does today
will it get a bunch of copycats probably
but you know kleenex still exists and
it's a hundred years later right so um
i don't know i mean we also own i own
like a bunch of restaurants and a bakery
and you know if people still like their
food as they have for the last 30 years
those will probably exist in 30 years
but we do own businesses that they're
you know platform dependent or
you know technology dependent where the
seas can change and there's no way to
predict how long they can go but i've
been surprised how long some of our
businesses have persisted and grown um
it just goes back to like you know not
not underestimating anything
and andrew i'm gonna give you one of the
the uh like
the devil's advocate to the
don't go for the big big home run
uh strategy which is
something else i believe is true i
believe it's true that
uh kind of like lifestyle business
and a big business a lifestyle business
and a moonshot business will both
basically take up all of your time
so might as well go big that's another
way of looking at it right uh so for
example i've i've run a restaurant i've
started a tech company in both cases it
was on my mind all the time i was
working on it you know five six days a
week you know at minimum as many hours
as i could i was trying to do it to make
it successful a restaurant was going to
be able to spit off you know 150 200 000
of profit off that location and you know
a tech company could be worth 100
million dollars in two years and so like
those are
just different sizes of the prize for
the same level of effort probability of
success i would say you know
you can do better restaurants not a
great example because they fail a lot
but like let's say dental clinic or
something
yeah a dental clinic you'd probably do
great but you'd have an agency or
whatever um so probably that's different
but also uh
with a bigger more ambitious project you
also
every day you get to be more excited
about it you get to recruit better
people because their great talent is
really excited about it versus like i
know like for example my online course
business i know i could do better for
hire people but like not everybody wants
to come work on that project for you
know and then i'm going to get somebody
who wants just that with is willing to
accept a salary that i can afford and
that's usually not the a plus person i
like to work with so you know you get
stuck in that middle middle zone yeah i
don't i'm not advocating for some tim
ferriss lifestyle work four hour work
week kind of thing i think um you know
warren buffett is not a lifestyle he
doesn't have a lifestyle business he has
a business he loves to run and he does
exactly what he wants to do but um
personally you know i like incubating
businesses starting new businesses
getting excited about stuff i just go i
do that off the side of my desk right so
that's 20 of my time 30 of my time um i
also like
buying great businesses and letting them
run and choosing ceos and doing the
buffett thing but i need excitement and
you know all the other stuff but i'm in
no way saying it's any less challenging
i'm just saying your odds of success are
higher and let's be real
if you go to the gym and you try and
lift um you know 800 pounds on your
bench on day one
you
probably will fail that doesn't feel
very good but if i give you an 80 pound
bench and you lift it you're going to
feel really good about yourself right
and so i just want to jump over the
one-foot hurdles right i want to feel
the sense of success and i think when
people start out in tech and they do a
startup and they fail and it's brutal a
lot of those people turn around and say
well i'm never doing that again when
they might have been great entrepreneurs
in some other format right i just think
it's the hardest lift it's the olympics
as you said
let's do one of these other topics uh
all right so i'm just gonna name it and
you give us your riff on it so
doing it wrong before you do it right
what's that yeah so i am i finally put
my finger on this because
i
people always criticize me because i
will hire
i'll hire the wrong person right i will
i'm a big advocate of if i have an idea
and i just want to get moving i will
just go and i'll hire whoever's in front
of me and i'll say hey let's go do this
and that does not work that well
obviously but what it does do is it
forces you to make it real right so um
you know for example um when i know i
want to go a direction i will do this so
i've always loved food in restaurants i
always dreamed of starting my own
restaurant
i did i started my own restaurant i went
and i signed a lease i shouldn't have i
hired the wrong manager
and i lost 800 grand right total
learning experience here's what it did
though it forced me into that industry
it made me learn it it made me make a
lot of mistakes and then i found the
good people through that so actually via
because i was in that restaurant that
failed i met the guy next door who ran a
very successful restaurant and when he
wanted when his partner
wanted to sell this the steak i ended up
buying it and now i own this wonderful
restaurant and i know it's good because
i've owned a bad restaurant right so
directionally moving into something and
i think people are way too pressure
precious with their hiring like they
just need to do it and then let people
go and it doesn't work out so that's
kind of what i mean by that too many
people
um think they're measuring twice but
cutting once and they just never cut
they just measure forever so but do you
just have to fire people all the time
no not all the time i mean like i've
gotten really lucky with lots of these
it's like 50 50. right um the pattern
that i've seen the best thing to do when
you're going into a new industry is look
for somebody who's actually succeeded
within it the problem is that when
you're when you're the rube at the table
when you're the newbie to the industry
uh even a [__] looks like a genius so
that's that's the hard part right
and i've certainly i've certainly made
that mistake before
and you've got this new business called
mailman right mailman the gmail plug-in
i've had that i've actually had that for
a couple years but yeah basically yeah
it basically it makes it so that you
only get email a couple times a day so
you're not putting your inbox all day
it's picking up steam it feels like
right now and uh you met a guy on
twitter who you got to run it right like
yeah that's an example if you're just
like yeah whatever you're you're an
engineer you seem like you might be able
to do this just do it 100 i'll do this
all the time so i literally um that same
year i did it twice um
i i tweeted out i said hey i've got this
idea for a gmail plug-in i need someone
to build it who wants to build it this
guy mohit in india messaged me sent me a
great email and he said tell me what you
wanted to do and i'll have it to you in
48 hours and he did and over and over
again he just kept delivering there was
another business idea i had where
i went to the guy i did the exact same
thing and he just didn't make any
progress and so i said hey after three
months it's not working out and went a
different direction but you know fifty
percent of the time it works really well
and now we not only have mailman but we
actually started a company a holding
company in india and we're looking at
acquisitions and we've got him managing
some of our businesses so it's been it's
been awesome
that's crazy
and this kind of like it feeds into this
idea like i wrote it down here but
taking chances on people which is the
most satisfying thing like i don't know
for you guys like when i was like 15 i
always had this feeling of like someone
just needs to give me a chance like i'm
a dog to a bone i just need the
opportunity and no one ever gave me that
chance no one ever saw that in me so i
had to start my own business
and um i had i've had this experience a
few times where i've taken a crazy
chance on someone like have i told you
guys about how i met my business partner
chris no
so uh maybe like two years into business
i
am a bank balance accountant so like you
sean i don't do bookkeeping i don't
understand what's going on i don't know
how to pay taxes i would just look at
the bank account and if the bank camp
was bigger on day 30 than it was on day
one i thought i was winning and
one day i go into the bank and i'm
trying to get a corporate credit card
and the teller says oh you need to go
talk to mr sparling he'll fill out all
the forms for you and so i go into the
back of the bank and i get welcomed into
this nice office and mr sparling looks
like the son of mr sparling he's like
this little skinny 23 year old and we
start chatting and immediately just hit
it off with this guy we're joking around
and talking about our days and our lives
and stuff and after i was done doing
this i go like hey what's your deal like
what you know do you want to stay at the
bank like what are you doing and he goes
well i'm thinking about getting my
accounting designation or something like
that i don't really know and i just
blurt out do you want to be my cfo
and he's kind of taken aback and he's
like hey like let's you know let's go
get a coffee tomorrow we'll talk about
it and i convince him to come and be my
cfo he has almost no accounting
experience uh he worked at a bank on
paper he's like the wrong guy to be a
cfo of a business at the time we're
doing over a million dollars i think
and
he just shows up on day one and i trust
him i give him my social security number
all my information banking wires
everything and chris is now my business
partner of 12 years he's responsible for
a significant amount of everything good
that's happened in my career and he's an
incredible person now for every story
like that i have you know someone who is
terrible and incompetent ranging from
that to fraudulent but when you do take
a chance on someone one in 10 times it
pays off big and so what i've struggled
with is not knowing you know obviously i
don't want to take that level of risk
still but i got to figure out a way to
give people chances i have do you think
that a large great story on that uh okay
i can tell the story of
same thing same thing they just have
i'll give you a good and a bad because
they both hit yesterday and um so i'll
give you the bad one first so the bad
one took a chance on a person who
um
honestly i still think this guy's a good
guy i like this guy he was a i met him
uh working out so he was a he trained
with my trainer he's like a workout
partner basically he came over to our
house and worked out with us one day
randomly
um nice guy young guy he was like an
apprentice plumber at the time so he's a
plumber in training
and with um and like we had a issue with
our 3pl for our e-commerce business
which was like we had a theft issue at
our at the warehouse that we were
working with and then the owner was kind
of like uh yeah i don't know
you can't prove that we stole it i'm
like dude
you have the goods and now they're gone
like who else who else stole it except
for someone at the warehouse he's like
ah let's check the cameras oh don't keep
the footage sorry so i just got so
pissed i was like we're leaving like
[__] tomorrow and so i was like all
right we're not using this 3p anymore
we're going to just do our own
warehousing i didn't know the first
thing about
warehousing but i was like okay whatever
i don't know we'll figure it out so we i
hastily signed a lease of this like 8
000 square foot warehouse near us and i
was like all right i definitely don't
want to run this warehouse but it's like
the stuff is coming tomorrow so we need
to uh find somebody so i i'm working out
that day and i'm like hey
you wanna
you wanna run a warehouse you say what
and i was like you know you're kind of
like a hard-working blue-collar guy like
you want to try this well i've never
really done anything like this
i was like don't worry like i'll take a
shot on you and like you're going to
make a bunch of mistakes that's okay i
understand because you've never done
this before i've also never done it
before let's figure it out together and
like you know you'll learn from this and
who knows like this might lead to a
future you want we had talked about what
he might want in the future like he
wanted to one day own real estate own
his own business i go you know this
could become that like if we open up a
second warehouse like
we'll buy that one and you know you
could be a part owner in it you could
run a basically
our own in-house 3pl like you could
fulfill not just our brand but other
brands too so i kind of laid out this
vision he was super excited about it and
in my head i'm already i do this thing
all the time samuel appreciate this i
always imagine the hustle con talk
this is like a phrase i use all the time
i go all right imagine two years from
now you're on stage talking about how we
growth hacked our way to success
what are the stories we're gonna tell or
like how we survived chaos and like
absolute like you know disasters but
still made it so i always work backwards
from like i imagine telling the story on
stage and it just gets me more excited
about the current moment and like so i
was already imagining like this plumber
this like apprentice plumber that we
hired that now is this amazing guy and
i'm like imagining all these great
things
and it started off good it was going
good but then like you know here we are
and you know a year later nine months
later something like that and
you know all of a sudden
balls being dropped on a couple things
and not really growing at the rate we
want to grow uh in terms of his growth
as a leader of that part of the business
but i'm still holding out hope and then
i find out he's kind of like
scamming us like trying to like start
his own thing he like sees us growing
and like trying to start his own version
of it and like
you know what like it's okay to be want
to be an entrepreneur and start your own
thing but like if you do it above board
i'm cool with it if you're kind of
on company time company dime like trying
to steal your idea like that's not cool
to me so so anyways i had this like kind
of that all came to a head yesterday and
i was like look this is not working i
guess you know like my bet was wrong
here this like my hope that we could
help this plumber guy become like this
like star like
throw that hustle contact away that's
not happening
and i'm feeling kind of bad and then the
afternoon i get a call from this guy
johnny
and johnny's a kid who i hired at i
think age 13 or 14 he called me one day
at the office and he goes hey is this
shawn i was like yeah how'd you get this
number who's this he goes my name is
johnny i met pete who works at your
office at the dog park i go okay and he
is everything okay with pete he's like
yeah yeah he said that you know i'm in
eighth grade and i'm a programmer and he
goes and i don't know any other
programmers um it's something it's about
to be summer and like i just want to
hang out around other programmers i've
never met one can i come hang out at
your office this summer
and i was like
how can i say i'll be a winner so i'm
like it's not me
i'm like okay this cold call is a yes so
he shows up and like the idea was he'll
just like he's going to be over there in
the corner he just wanted to like shadow
the environment or like whatever first
day i was like uh we're in a meeting i
was like oh you know what we should do
we should do this like viral little quiz
we don't have enough people to do it i
was like hey johnny get in here johnny
can you build a website he's like uh
yeah like he didn't know how to but he's
just like yeah i think i could and i was
like all right build this today and he
like literally stayed there until
midnight that day and like had a version
of it working by that night probably was
under like such an immense amount of
pressure now that i look back at it
probably poor guy like you know aged the
guy probably five years so anyways he he
just joins us full time as an eighth
grader
by 10th grade
it's like johnny needs to be here full
time johnny's the man johnny's the
[__] man he's like hanging out with a
bunch of like old neckbeards like us
and uh and and he's like and i want to
drop out of high school and i just want
to do this and his mom is so worried
about him dropping out and i like go and
i meet with his mom and i'm like man
he's not dropping out he's going pro
it's like when lebron james he skipped
college because he was going pro he was
just that advanced and like she was like
okay if you put it that way that sounds
good like i don't feel bad about my kid
anymore you know like okay if you say so
and so and then he became when we got
acquired he became the youngest amazon
employee i think
in all of amazon at that during the
acquisition
and now he's like starting his own he's
now he's i don't know 19 or something
like that and he's the kid's name give
him
johnny dallas johnny dallas i don't know
i'll pull up his twitter awesome
so he has his own startup now and it's
like he just called me yesterday he's
like yeah um it's going pretty good like
we just got a term sheet from you know
i guess i probably shouldn't say the
firm but it's like
the best vc firm so he's like the best
vc firm just gave us a term sheet you
know
38 million post valuation i was like
johnny
you know have you had puberty yet what's
going on dude like this is crazy to me
but that was and i told him i go
dude he goes thanks for just making the
time i go bro you don't understand this
is the best feeling i can get it's like
i feel like i bet on you you were my
personal angel investment and like we
became friends and then you're actually
doing the thing you like actually did
the thing that i always hope somebody
does which is like take the opportunity
and just [__] run with it and become
a superstar and like when it happens
it's so worth it and you're like all
right i'll do this 10 more times even if
i whiff nine more times if there's
another johnny in there like this is
this is gold for me
totally there's nothing better than when
it does work but it's so painful when it
doesn't because you're just going like
dude don't you see this right like that
guy you gave the opportunity to you know
he could have owned the business with
you and done the real estate and all the
other stuff one question what was what
were the warning signs that that guy
wasn't going to be the guy because chris
has this thing about he calls it
gumption it's like if you say to them
um hey balls in your court
do they follow up within 24 hours do
they move the ball forward are they do
they have cases
before you even gave me that example you
go what were the red flags or the bad
signs it was exactly this
during one of the workouts after we
brought them on board we're still
working out together and i go i go dude
here's my vision for you like what's the
dream he gave me this idea like i want
to own real estate it's like dude at the
moment you have no pathway to real
estate you have like you're just making
enough to live let alone and you don't
know anything about real estate so like
you know
he didn't really know his path and i
told him i said here's the plan we're
going to open up another warehouse i
want to own real estate let's buy it
i'll give you a piece and you run it you
you and we turn this into a business
where you actually are running your own
business inside that real estate as our
own 3pl because i know this that
e-commerce is booming is a good idea
and i didn't hear from him like he was
in the moment he was like oh wow that's
awesome yeah that's great
and then there was no follow-up for
three months
and then i met up with him and he was
and he was in the other boat he goes
yeah like i wanted to like talk more
about that but i didn't hear from you
and i was like
you know i thought maybe maybe you would
like you know i've really been excited
about that i've been thinking about it
i've been i was research i was googling
some places i go bro
if that was me and somebody's late if
somebody gives me a window into a life i
want i'm like knock knock knock hey
about that thing you said
but you know here's exactly what i'm
planning to do to move the ball forward
hey here's a couple links hey i put
together a spreadsheet hey i'm making a
checklist of like
we can do this if i hit these goals and
like you gotta do the work at that point
and so the biggest red flag was that he
didn't follow up
on that opportunity
it's not that he didn't want to he just
didn't know that that's what you're
supposed to do and it wasn't his natural
inclination to like to do that and i
noticed that with johnny it's the
opposite it's like
tell johnny something he'll if you give
him an inch he'll take a mile type of
guy they'll tell he'll text you at nine
o'clock at night and say hey check this
out check out the website i'm working on
this guy that i i gave the other
opportunity to obviously i won't share
any details about it but he i emailed
him and i said dude i haven't heard from
you in two months what's going on and he
goes yeah i've i redesigned the website
take a look and i was like you should
have sent me this on day one when you
had a design show me there's momentum
instead we've lost all this momentum and
yeah it's it's crazy but there's no
better high by the way i just found
another guy like this and i'll tell you
the signs that i know i'll bet right now
this guy's gonna be a winner so this
guy's i didn't know this until i hired
him he's just graduated from college
he's got like a dot edu email address
but he had emailed me being like hey
heard you on the pod talk about
something like you know you want to give
you want to do some philanthropy he goes
here's a better idea let's create a
micro grant where you give out like
whatever it is some amount of money that
that's you're cool with and like write a
grant for people who who do something i
know you're all about action and making
[__] happen so like
give it away to people who are going to
make [__] happen that's better than
charity it'll feel better for you so the
guy like knows me he reached out
intelligently he says he's doing the
same thing he doesn't pitch his company
which by the way is meant to be
he was trying to start like a microgrid
like angelus for grants instead of like
startups it's like a way to quickly spin
up like a grant program
and i was like you got my attention but
you know i was like yeah i'm interested
that sounds like a great idea let's uh
whatever
and then he followed up like 10 times in
the next like 12 days he was like hey
here's three ideas for what your grant
could be tell me which of those three
you like just send back the number one
two or three then he's like hey i saw
your tweet about this other thing
remember the grant thing you should do
this instead of that right and he just
kept following up intelligently each
time so i was like already like this
guy's a winner and i told him i go hey
dude i don't have a ton of time for this
grant thing but like you're awesome if
you ever want to like do something like
and he was like no no i want to try this
grant thing
anyways long story short like six months
goes by he ends up graduating he takes a
job at like a i don't want to say which
place but like takes a job at like kind
of like a hot startup that we know of
and then i get an email out of the blue
three days ago subject line i've made an
irreversible decision
so another great sign is like his
copywriting is good for like a 21 year
old he knows how to like frame it he
goes i made it a real decision i quit my
job yesterday even though it was a great
job and they they offered me whatever
um because i've decided that i want to
come work for you and make xyz happen he
goes wow he goes you know i have a
couple other ideas of what i might do
but you're the top of the list anyways
he makes you feel good does the flattery
thing says exactly what he would do he
goes i have two ideas for how i would uh
make the milk road better um let me know
if you're down to hear them and i'll
send them over all right so he baits me
i'm like yeah of course something ideas
send you ideas
and i just reply i go
i didn't honestly i didn't care about
your ideas i just want to hire you and
now he's working with me and he's
already awesome and we're on day three
so i can tell you this guy his name is
safwan safwan is gonna be a winner and i
bet you like six months from now i'm
gonna be talking about how amazing this
guy is
dude the problem that's my problem with
with all this though is
all three of us i get so much inbound
and i'm like i don't wanna i'm not in
the mood to figure out who's legit and
who's not and also i don't wanna have to
train someone i don't want to have to
manage someone at the moment so are you
guys getting exhausted managing people
are you getting worn out like having to
talk to people all the time and tell
them what to do or to give you feedback
sean
sean i would love to know how you do
this you've kind of alluded to it a few
times that you have a team helping you
kind of manage channels or at least
looking at opportunities and stuff how
does that work because i have that same
problem where people email me ideas all
the time and there's nowhere for it to
go there's no one to help
yeah that's okay that's by design it's
like it's meant to be a bottomless pit
of like no reply but then we like cherry
pick interesting things and just like
pull it out of that that that well
dripping wet we're like oh you know
maybe we should reply to this but
basically my version of of chris right
your business chris mine is ben and
basically ben has the keys he has my
email and he has my twitter and that's
the two biggest forms of inbound and
basically he's the wall and it's like if
you can climb the ben wall then like
you've made it and like ben knows what's
interesting and what's not and so like
and that's like one of his main things
is like he likes he gets energy from
that whereas i kind of like
i lose energy doing it like you say i'm
like i kind of i don't enjoy doing it
whereas he's like oh yeah this guy sent
me this thing so i checked it out and
then i chatted with him i'm like dude i
would never check it out or chat with
him he's like yeah that's what i like
checking things out and then if it's
cool then i like to chat with them and
i'm like yeah you make it sound normal
but like dude i [__] hate doing that
and so and then he just replies
basically as me to them and they he sets
up the call and then half the time i
don't show up on the call it's just like
they're like is sean coming and it's
like ben's like nah it's just me uh go
and like it's a good counter too
because like if they're like you know
offended by that or whatever it's
probably not gonna work because i don't
have enough time to dedicate to each
individual person if you're if you're
just trying to meet me that's one thing
versus if you're trying to
like advance your cause your mission
your project or whatever then like
you'll take help from ben or anybody
right like you shouldn't be like on your
high horse about it so to me the answer
the secret answer is like it's basically
ben and ben knows the tight filter of
like what's interesting and what's not
because we are like so in sync with each
other right we talk all the time about
like
about little nuggets or hooks that are
interesting and if he finds something
he'll hang it on that hook
sam have you ever explored delegating
your email
yeah yeah i've explored it for some
reason
i not pounced on it like i should but i
probably should do that shouldn't i i
mean i miss so many emails that i just
don't read chris and i did it about
six months ago we we started using front
and so our our assistant actually reads
all the emails and it goes into her
inbox first and then she chooses what we
need to respond to so it's like oh
here's a docusign that goes to the
general counsel here's a venture deal it
goes to the rolling fund so i don't
actually see any of it and it's really
reduced my email
by you know even though the volume is
the same but for me it's reduced it by
70 percent because in the end the yeah
every single email you have to even
archive is like mentally taxing my thing
is that once after i sold the business i
didn't have um a business i didn't have
a business so i was like i'm not i don't
want to justify
i couldn't justify having uh someone
you know doing stuff i didn't want to
have like a higher burn just for
personal reasons now that i do have some
things brilliant maybe um maybe i can
actually have cash flow coming in from a
business then i think yeah it's worth
justifying it which is crazy because i
don't understand sean how you set all
your stuff up because you got like
it seems like a lot of different things
coming in so your accounting must be
horrendous i mean it must be a huge
headache
huge mess yeah you gotta go to the bank
and find your cfo yeah but by the way
that little thing you said that's so
true i i always say this hire your
favorite vendors and your favorite sales
people so like anytime you have an
amazing account like experienced account
manager or a banker like i had this one
woman who helped me with my mortgage and
i was like hey if you ever want to like
switch careers like
you're amazing and like same thing with
like you know my trainer different
people i'm like yo you have this like
great way with people or like the guy
who manages our rolling fund uh he's
like he works at angellist but this
[__] handles like such a [__] so
we'll send it we'll be like hey we're
doing this deal we don't know like half
the terms and it's gonna uh we have to
sign now and why are the money in three
months is it connor yeah connor he's
amazing
i don't know how he tracks all this yeah
we the same thing will be like 100k into
this and then like he handles everything
and i'm just like this is insane
connor's a absolute magician and it's so
funny that you have the same guy because
he's he is so on top of it and i'm just
like
conor you are like like i need to
basically like as soon as i have enough
operational [__] to deal with i'm like
conor's the first call because this guy
handles the messiest most disorganized
thing and he's just like yep got it
never makes me feel bad about it he just
like solves the problem and if he needs
something he tells me and then i give it
to him like it's so nice when you find
somebody like ultra competent like that
it's four seasons service right i don't
know if you guys are gonna you go to
four seasons and you you know you say oh
like i really you say something fussy
like oh i want you know a thinner
blanket and at some hotels they grumble
and there they just say oh yes we would
we would love to sir and i feel like and
then they'll never complain or anything
and i feel like um conor is one of those
people uh and my assistant is one of
those people those people are just
they're they're amazing when you find
one you just gotta i'll tell you one
more signal
somebody who thinks bigger than you um
especially if they aren't the one in
charge of the company this is super rare
it just happened safwan did this so i
brought him in to work on the milk road
nft projects like we're going to launch
an nfd as part of milk road we're
brainstorming what it could be and we
don't want to just do some [__]
thing we want it to be like really great
and he was like it's like his first or
second day he just goes you know just a
thought like
um
right now we kind of think of this as
like some sub little project like a like
a cool add-on to the milk road he's like
but there's no reason this shouldn't be
like as big as board ape yacht club or
anything else like this could be
one of the biggest best nft projects
around i just want to say that out loud
because like
i don't want to limit that and i was
just like
you know if you can make me feel like a
little [__] then like you are my
favorite employee right because i'm like
oh yeah i if i'm not thinking
sufficiently large enough or
aggressive enough about either a
timeline
or a size of the prize
that's the you know that's my favorite
type of person to work with is somebody
who pushes my thinking on like couldn't
we do this faster or couldn't we do this
bigger because
that's normally like normally people
will just accept whatever the leader
sets as the frame they'll just set that
as this invisible walls around how good
or how big or how fast something can be
and somebody who breaks those walls is
like a winner
dude sean how much more hyped are you
around milk road than some of your other
things it seems like this is the most
hyped
like it's
it feels good so you're 33 it's taken
you of 33 years to finally find the
thing where it it's like this is this is
what i should be doing like the it's you
know ikigai it's like what you're good
at what the world wants what the world's
willing to pay for and like what you're
passionate about
right in the middle you've you've seen
like you've found that whereas before
you found things that made money but it
was like it's kind of interesting then
you found things that you're passionate
didn't really make money
now you've got you're in the center
yeah i think that's true maybe the
podcast is also a good example of that
but um
yeah
on that note you have this thing called
five pillars of happiness
what are the things oh yeah what are the
five pillars
so chris has all these uh all these
sticks and stuff but one of them one of
them is sparling's five pillars of
happiness and i it's very simple but i
think it's really it's really absolutely
and he counts them out for you so he'll
say um see family every day right
obviously um see friends and loved ones
multiple times a week be in nature once
a week new and novel experiences once a
month and then feel like a man or a
woman go with your buddies go hunting
sports whatever makes you feel tough and
gritty and ticks that box for your
caveman brain once a quarter right and
it's like kind of this very simple model
we we built this little circle of it
where you can rank yourself on it but i
was like this is actually like kind of a
thing i i feel like more people should
uh should use this system sam does it in
the reverse he sees his family once a
quarter and every day he does his
caveman [__]
he's doing everything
i do think that that that it's kind of
interesting sean do you do any caveman
stuff
yeah for sure the workout is that i play
sports i play basketball i compete i
think that's kind of like the version of
that uh
and then sometimes i'll just do like uh
manual labor i'll just like be like okay
i'm gonna [__] assemble this thing
that's been sitting here like it's not
the most manly thing but it's like right
you know something i don't really need
to do and i'm just going to like just
put my full focus into using my hands
and like trying to like make something
or build something or do something
that's more rare it's so weird like i
have a trainer i do power lifting as
well and it's so funny like you're
basically paying someone to come to your
house to have you simulate doing labor
during right yeah and it's amazing like
i always feel
you know my happiest in the hour after
my workout or whatever and you just go
oh even that that's caveman brain right
you would have been building a log cabin
or doing something manly and now we're
so pathetic that we have to pay other
men to have a simulate data for us in
our houses right but yeah it's kind of
green stuff too so you do boxing sam
right i got it he does that for me bjj
if you've ever done jiu jitsu it's like
yeah wrestling they're like so primal
and like such a good feeling when you're
done
boxing has been awesome i love
like fighting i think it's it's awesome
it's in a controlled environment it's
badass and that's awesome and then i'm
at this ranch now and i i have been so
happy like i'm trying to figure out how
to build a fence and i'm not literally
going to build the fence but like i'm
like
you having to like move stuff to you
know you're doing a little bit of work
to like figure out how is this going to
work or you know where we're going to
put a pool just like [__] like that i
have found to be so much more rewarding
than internet stuff the problem is is
that internet stuff is still also
awesome and makes so much more money
with so
little effort compared to like having to
construct a pool uh but so i think sean
i feel like you're similar to me in that
you're looking for shortcuts you want to
delegate everything you know
everything's doordashed assistance chef
you know all that stuff right
i'm the exact same way and i did this
thing where i did a um i had a
psychologist do a 360 on me i heard
about this one of my favorite investors
this guy um manish pabrai did this thing
where he hired a psychologist to
basically write an operating manual and
say here's what you're missing in your
life uh here's the brutal feedback your
friends and family have about you here's
how you need to improve and so i heard
this on the past i was driving i i i
think it was 10 grand and so he spent
like four hours interviewing me we did a
whole bunch of testing and then he
talked to like my six
six i think it was three friends and
family members and three um
three people i work with and i got it
back and it was absolutely one of the
most brutal experiences of my entire
life like our brains are not or we're
not designed to know what our friends
say about us and stuff but one of the
key
key things he said to me is he goes
um
you're it's almost like all of your
friends have come to you and said andrew
on saturday let's mow the lawn together
and then afterwards we're going to
celebrate and we're going to have a cold
beer so we're all going to sit in a
circle and you know be all sweaty and
papa papa corona or whatever and i just
say nah it's cool i just got a guy on
taskrabbit and he's going to do that so
i never get the sense of satisfaction of
doing the work and i never get the
camaraderie of doing it with anyone and
you're right you're right it is doing
real labor doing no i know but it that
was the feedback and i was like holy
[__] that's so true and sean i feel like
you're probably similar
yeah except it's my wife telling me at
all times to go [__] do the work
instead of like hiring a man to come
hang you know to like literally like
hang a poster on my wall
which by the way
me and my wife one of our biggest fights
over the last couple years was i didn't
like wheeling the garbage out to the
street because it would always be like
10 o'clock at night i'd be in my boxers
you know and i finally i was like oh
there's a private garbage service
they'll take all of our recycling this
is awesome my wife looked at me like i
just like you know she i didn't defend
her in a physical fight or something it
was like i lost all respect my wife like
wouldn't have sex with me for weeks
it's not good she gave me that jada that
jada smith look um exactly
yeah except i didn't slap anyone i just
cowered yeah
that's why will did it was like oh [__]
this is the moment this is i can get out
of the doghouse about the trash right
now but the worst pain is when you like
hire a cleaning lady or something and i
see her like try to like move the trash
can down the thing and it's like heavy
i'm like oh [__] i can't come on come on
just move i got it it's all good
like uh
you gotta feel that deal so fascinating
it's so fascinating though to think
about like we do so little labor
compared to someone 75 years ago and
there's a value if you grew up in a
farming family your parents would think
you're pathetic if you don't grow your
own
vegetables right so it's like where do
you end where you know what's what's the
right amount of labor and what's the
wrong amount because i also know people
who they're wealthy and yet they spend
all their time doing miserable tasks
they hate you know cleaning the cat's
litter box taking out the garbage and
i'm like hey just delegate this hire
someone and they hate it you know
they're fighting with their wife over it
you know it's miserable so i think
there's a balance
uh dude you didn't need to spend the 10k
you could have just asked your cleaning
lady nobody knows you better than your
cleaning lady and or you're you're a
nanny or somebody like that like they
my cleaning lady doesn't speak english i
actually have to i text her in spanish
uh so she doesn't know anything
at least that's when i think maybe she's
actually
she knows where you leave your underwear
on the floor and [__] like that
she knows how long that couple sit on
your desk before you just finally take
it to the sink she knows everything
all right bros i gotta bounce i have
someone here but you guys gonna keep
talking
uh no we can wrap it it's cool yeah
that's fine it won't be the same without
you all right uh let's let's wrap it up
ben uh ben what'd you think
uh making me come on camera here on on
my sick day but uh great stuff of always
a great absolute episode from andrew i
anticipate this is gonna be one of our
top download ones it usually is
did we uh awesome
ben i said that we crossed 100k per
episode that was like only for a handful
or what what do you know what the
numbers are they just like what's your
actual average like what's our actual
average i don't know the actual
but it depends what window you're
looking at if it's i think most people
measure it by a 60-day window
yeah whatever 30-60 is fine
all right let me just let me just pull
up the stats have you guys considered
like building in public and having a
graph or something or with that dude i
tweeted out it starts going down
i know you talk about it a lot our march
numbers i tweeted out it was
1.5
1.6 million whatever the number it was
something like that
that includes youtube though that
includes only people who watch full
youtube videos as opposed to just the
clips if you add in the clips yesterday
sean your video about lamar ball or
lavar ball i don't even know anything
they made fun of me all in the comments
because i don't know who these people
are it got
400 000 views in like 24 hours or
something like that 400 on what
you dude you realize what are your
videos right now on youtube youtube
shorts has like millions and millions of
views
yeah
dude it's got like thousands of comments
and people just roasting uh me and a
little bit of you
it literally probably has tens of
millions of views getting fancy
youtube sucks
does it really have tens of millions of
views
yeah you just get bullied by like 14
year olds if you yeah and they're all
way better looking they all wear vans
like i got super excited about our tic
tac tic tac videos i was like oh sick a
million views they're probably saying
how useful and helpful this content was
right
can you open up the comments
it's just like
there's nothing good in the comments for
us right like you know i'm hairy ugly
and dumb and you're like you know i
don't know i don't know i don't know
what they say about you i was just too
focused on me
what all right
you won't know the numbers so so i think
what you were talking about was the
other day it's for the first time we
have youtube videos with
we have multiple youtube videos with
over 200 000 views which is good and uh
these are not like the
short tick tock style videos like actual
videos with uh with a couple hundred
thousand uh in terms of just podcast our
top
downloaded episode is at seventy
thousand
um
all time
just all time
uh but if you throw on youtube it
crosses a hundred thousand
um so how much how much of your growth
has come from doing all that tick tock
stuff where you're like oh we'll give
out i forget you're giving up money or
something like that for the person who
takes stuff viral
it's hard to say
yeah yeah it's like
i mean that definitely worked um
but we were doing other stuff at the
same time so it's hard to say how much
of that came from that oh hey when are
you guys doing this summit what's the
deal with that
i don't know can i read you the top
three top five comments on that video
that has three million views on youtube
this is exactly what i'm talking about
right here's comment number one
this is what people say when they just
read the headlines that comment has six
thousand likes
number two
there's a guy in the nba that alone told
us everything he has no clue what he's
talking about
okay fair enough i
know a lot about the mba um
this guy reminds me of myself in college
when i was giving a talk about a pro
about a topic the professor taught and
i'd only skim reading 10 minutes before
the class that has 2000 likes
um please stop covering sports all of
this information is either the wrong or
in the wrong series of events
okay
damn all right
all right i gotta go talk to y'all soon
[Music]
you